Vielleicht habt ihr schon mal vom us raumfahrt unternehmen rockend lab gehört es bietet kommerzieller
raketen vorgehens alan 50 flüge pro jahr sollen es schon bald sein bei dem beispielsweise
Forschungssatelliten in ihrer umlaufbahn abgesetzt werden können und dieser plan läuft ganz gut der ersten starts waren erfolgreich welche technik steckt dahinter
Wie hoch sind die. Kosten und bedeutet dass tatsächlich eine neue ära in der raumfahrt
Ihr habt euch dieses super spannende thema öfter bei whatsapp gewünschte bekommt ist deshalb
Und zwar alle fragen zum thema beantwortet herzlich willkommen bei pixum science fiction
Es geht um die zukunft der raumfahrt und dieses mal ausnahmsweise nicht. Um elon musk space is open für business
So lautet das motto des privaten raumfahrtunternehmens rocket lab mit dem ziel mit weltraumflügen geld
Zu machen wurde es 2006 gegründet und seitdem entwickelt das unternehmen mehrstufige trägerrakete
Und antriebssysteme die satelliten in den weltraum befördern künftig sollen pro jahr etwa
50 kommerzielle flüge angeboten werden also etwa einer pro woche das ist eine menge im jahr 2009 startete die
Erste höhen forschungsrakete von roccat lab ins all sie erreichte mit ihrem 60 kilogramm eine
Höhe von 120 kilometern und konnte eine nutzlast von zwei kilogramm befördern die nächste entwicklungsstufe wurde
Dann, mit der elektron rakete erreichte
ihr habt vielleicht schon
Einmal davon gehört 150 kilogramm soll sie in die erdumlaufbahn bringen doch der erste start der rakete mit dem namensschild
Testing im mai 2017 gegen schief sie hatte den
Geplanten hobbit nicht ganz erreicht der zweite test im jahr 2018 dagegen war ein grund zum. Jubeln die cube satz
wurden erfolgreich in die erdumlaufbahn
Gebracht kurz zur erklärung das sind nano satelliten die oft auch als helden des weltraums
Bezeichnen wenn sie sind preiswert und klein und spielen deswegen bei der erforschung des weltalls eine immer größere rolle egal ob die überwachung von
Asteroiden die der erde gefährlich werden. Könnten oder beim mars. Missionen. Konkret handelt es sich bei dieser mission mit dem namen swiss testing
um den erdbeobachtungssatelliten
Darf pioneer. Und um 2. Uhr zwei satelliten die wetterdaten erfassen sollen
und zudem auch die aufgabe haben schiffe
Zu tracken rocket lab hat sogar, einen, eigenen raum fahrten bahnhof. Und zwar auf der neuseeländischen
Halbinsel na ja das ist tatsächlich der weltweit einzige
Weltraumbahnhof in privatbesitz von dort waren die beiden flügel losgegangen das erfolgsergebnis von anfang des jahres lässt das unternehmen
Große, visionen haben, raumflüge könnten deutlich billiger werden als bislang pro stadt werden
kosten von etwa
4,9 millionen us-dollar kalkuliert dass in etwa 4,4 millionen euro das ist ein absolutes schnäppchen
Triebwerke werden beispielsweise durch 3d drucker, hergestellt, und so konnten die. Kosten bereits jetzt
Gesenkt werden weitere elektromagneten die jeweils 150 kilogramm in den mitbringen könnten sind in der produktion
Spezialisiert sind sie voll und ganz auf leichte ladungen wie eben
Kommunikationssatelliten die firmen nutzen, um, naturkatastrophen zum, beispiel vorherzusagen oder die. Meere, zu beobachten also ganz
Kleine lasten aber oft reicht das eben doch die. Angepeilten 50 raumflüge pro jahr. Könnten theoretisch sogar. Noch getoppt werden, denn die lizenz erlaubt
120 doch selbst wenn das unternehmen nur die 50 starts pro jahr. Schaffen würde könnte sich
So ein teil des marktes erobern rocket lab erhofft sich beispielsweise aufträge von der nasa. Im januar twitterte das unternehmen
Jedenfalls today maxe beginning of new area in commercial access to space ja wenn
Ihr kein video zum thema zukunft der raumfahrt. Und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp
Und in anderen messengern nur dann verpasst er kein video den die abo box auf youtube die ist ja immer
Ein, bisschen lückenhaft über die messenger erfahrt. Ihr von mir auch. Noch vor allen. Anderen vom neuesten video täglich garantiert
Einfach hier draufklicken. Und dann geht es automatisch weiter. Und zur begrüßung habe ich. Ein kleines goodie
noch dazu gepackt, und am besten auch mein schwesterkanal klicks
Um, social media abonnieren das geht hier dafür hat, er, das neueste aus der social media wird
Aktuell die anhörung von mark zuckerberg vor dem europäischen parlament aber nicht die glocke vergessen also ich mach's nochmal
Genau, hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken fällt in heavy die revolution der raumfahrt ansonsten bis. Dann
bleibt